Jourdan Schultz has been on the story
Yahoo Sports basketball insider kind
enough to join us Jordan good morning
thanks for joining us your exchange with
Bryan Colangelo yesterday via text said
what do you think well first of all it
was you know I don't know I don't know
what happened this is not me
and he elaborated by saying that you
know someone set him up clearly you know
this is not me and someone set me up and
then he added later on by saying I'm not
a hundred percent certain or I'm not
certain that I was deliberately set up
but again this is clearly not me and he
just said he wants it to be resolved
quickly so we can move on
the tricky thing for him Dan is that
aside from potentially losing
credibility and you know if this is true
is that he's in LA he's been in LA for
côté workouts and there's a lot of other
executives around it's a very strange
story and it's an unprecedented story
for not just basketball but for all
American sports
I've never as you've never seen anything
like this before but also I want to know
maybe how the other GM's front office
people could be viewing us and and it's
gonna be used against the 76ers come
free agency time so did you talk to
anybody yesterday on the outside looking
in yes since Tuesday night I've had
conversations with executives Scouts
even this morning with one asking what's
your take and they've all said the same
thing which is that based on the article
and you know their conversations are on
a league is that they can't see a
situation or a it wasn't Brian and
seeing where he would maintain his job
with what Philadelphia and so that that
didn't surprise me but it was
interesting that they all had the same
opinion and obviously like you said it's
not a hundred percent fair and so you
know for certain but their entire
everyone I spoke with said the same
thing that they can't imagine a
situation where it wasn't him or at
least attached to this if it was his
wife and we've seen instances in sports
in recent memory where you've had wives
who have defended their husbands so I
but even then if that's the case it's
tiles like I don't know
how Bryan Colangelo keeps his job if if
it's his wife who was using these burner
phones yeah I mean if she if she did so
I don't think it was malicious I think
it was you know maybe out of a good
place but it just got out of hand I had
I had breakfast with them with Bryan and
Barbara about six weeks ago and you know
there's no way that this was a malicious
act by Barbara you know these are nice
people I think they got this got out of
hand for one of them perhaps and then it
just spiraled and you have five-burner
accounts now one of which they've
admitted was Brian and the other for the
wringer is saying was was obviously news
as well yeah and I think they're looking
at the last couple of numbers of her
phone number or her and and and they're
matching that up with it so I don't know
what kind of forensic evidence we're
gonna have how how deep does
Philadelphia want to go in investigating
this well that that's the thing and it's
not just so Nelson now it's week two at
some point what at what point does the
league get involved because this is so
embarrassing for the NBA I mean you know
I would imagine such a 20-18 story to
this kind of digital footprint of
investigative journalism but I think the
Sixers want to go deep because they want
to resolve this swiftly and quickly and
that's also been the sentiment that I've
gotten from other executives around the
league is that regardless of what their
decision is the Sixers deeps a quickly
because the more it goes on the worse
that gets it just needs to get they need
to make a decision soon but also the
timing of this with free agency looming
here who would LeBron but but who would
be out to sabotage the 76ers here
because they like somebody leaked this
weather his wife was you know there was
her burner accounts and Brian gave her
information somebody leaked this though
Jordan yeah well that's the thing is
like there was that sentiment yesterday
that it was Santa Nicki I don't buy out
at all is what what would be his endgame
he's not with another team I I would I
would imagine that for a business wise
this could really hurt them whether or
not you think LeBron would go there is
almost
material because they have other other
pieces to consider as well I have a
young team that they're trying to fill
the championship team around so yeah it
would it would behoove another it'll get
hoob another team to leak it but i think
right now like i don't think anybody who
the citrus really knows what's what's
going on that's why you haven't had a
decision yet good stuff Jordan thanks
for joining us as always we appreciate
it thanks Ben aperture that's Jordan
Schultz yahoo sports basketball insider
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]